ALSO THIS MORNING SAID HE WAS
SAID TO IMPOSE A TARIFF.
>> Bret: THE ADMINISTRATION IS
ALSO DEALING WITH A PUBLIC
RELATIONS MESS TONIGHT INVOLVING
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN.
OFFICIALS SAY THERE ARE REPORTS
THAT NEARLY 1500 KIDS ARE LOST
BUT IT’S JUST NOT TRUE.
ED HENRY LOOKS OUT THE FACTS
TONIGHT.
>> WHEN IVANKA TRUMP POSTED THIS
PHOTO WITH HER YOUNG SON THIS
WEEKEND, THE TROPEZ OF COMIC
HATERS GOT TRIGGERED.
THEY RELEASED A TAX SAYING SHE
NOT CARE ABOUT MIGRANT KIDS AND
WANTED TO KNOW WHERE THE
CHILDREN WERE.
OVER 1400 MIGRANT CHILDREN HAVE
GONE MISSING AND BLAMED
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR ORDERING
BABIES TO BE SEPARATED FROM
THEIR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT PARENTS.
EVEN THE WHITE HOUSE SPOKESMAN
LOGAN GIDLEY AND HEROES OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES FIRED BACK TODAY.
NONE OF THOSE CHARGES ARE TRUE.
>> THAT IS IN INACCURATE
CHARACTERIZATION
CHARACTERIZATION OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
THE GOVERNMENT WILL TRY TO
PROSECUTE EVERYONE WHO CROSSES
THE SOUTHWEST BORDER ILLEGALLY.
EVEN THOSE SEEKING ASYLUM.
THAT WILL LEAD TO SOME PARENTS
BEING SEPARATED FROM THEIR
CHILDREN, WHICH IS ALREADY PART
OF EXISTING LAW.
>> IF YOU ARE SMUGGLING A CHILD,
THEN WE WILL PROSECUTE YOU.
AND THAT CHILD MAY BE SEPARATED
FROM YOU AS REQUIRED BY LAW.
>> THE 1475 KIDS WHO ALLEGEDLY
WENT MISSING ARRIVED AT THE
BORDER FROM OCTOBER THROUGH
DECEMBER 2017, MONTHS BEFORE THE
SESSION’S POLICY WENT INTO
EFFECT.
SECONDLY HHS OFFICIALS POINTED
OUT THAT THOSE KIDS WERE A TOTAL
OF CHILDREN THAT THEY SURVEYED
OVER THOSE THREE MONTHS WE
SHOWED AT THE BORDER WITHOUT
PARENTS.
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
TOOK THE EXTRA STEP OF PLACING
OVER 7,000 KIDS WITH THE ADULT
SPONSORS IN THE U.S.
HHS FOUND 6,500 OF THE KIDS
STILL LIVING WITH SPONSORS.
FIVE WERE DEPORTED, AND HHS
OFFICIALS SAY SOME OF THEIR
SPONSORS ARE HERE ILLEGALLY,
LIKELY DODGING THE GOVERNMENT’S
ATTEMPTS TO CONTACT THEM.
ERIC HARTIGAN SAID" THE
ASSERTION THAT UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN ARE LOST IS FALSE.
THIS IS A CLASSIC EXAMPLE OF THE
A DODGE, NO GOOD DEED GOES
UNPUNISHED.
THAT INCLUDED JOURNALIST FROM
COMPOUNDING THE
MISCHARACTERIZATIONS.
INCLUDING THIS PHOTO FROM
AZCENTRAL.COM.
IT WAS A PHOTO OF LATINO
CHILDREN BEING HELD IN CAGES.
THE PROBLEM WAS THAT IMAGE WAS
TAKEN IN 2014 WHEN BARACK OBAMA
WAS PRESIDENT.
>> REPUBLICAN MARCO RUBIO IS A
CRITIC OF THE PRESIDENT BUT,